27 prima reeves fantastic video of the
year birmania aung fucking world right
now
che schifo con ragazzi volevo fare una
roba un lupo un poco diversa allora come
potete vedere questo splendido mondi cui
viviamo nella b balilla è diventato
tutto mega gigante volevo ragazzi fare
una cosa molto simpatica come
effettivamente è da un po di tempo che
ormai viviamo tutti qua nelle nostre
case
volevo volevo levarmi poi dalle palle
cioè nel senso nel senso pratico come
del fatto di andarmene a quel paese
prendendo tutto il possibile di
materiali arresto magari lo butto fuori
perché far parte chandon sarò ma non
sarà un cacchio mi prendo i materiali
che mi servono e faccio una cosa molto
interessante me ne vado più lontano
possibile per vedere se riesco
allontanandomi a trovare un posto
abbastanza segreto all'estremo della
mappa della big money le vediamo che
succede
step1 buttiamo tutto quello che non ci
serve fuori acqua quindi rob è
sostanzialmente abbastanza inutili
questa me la mettono perché ciò le dita
ok mi tengo la colle perché vi servirà
sicuramente prendiamo allora torce
piccone va bene legna tantissima cibo va
bene ce l'ho e mi serve tutta sta roba
perché ovviamente poi andremo in un
punto imprecisato del pianeta e mette un
attimo in ordine perché devo capire un
secondo loro ok ok perché c'è una palla
di babele ho fatto la pariglia amante
non mi ricordo anche più sexy e il
momento di volarsene nei meandri
dell'ignoto del server della big money
la vediamo dove cacchio arrivo sbagliato
direzione non arriva
non lo so è lagato giu non lo so ma è il
momento speriamo che la mia casa seppure
incustodita rimarrà non preda di
attacchi di dirigente che la slot ci
siamo al momento incredibile me ne vado
dalla parte opposta dove non è mai
andato nessuno sono morto non è vero
ok let's go madonna ragazzi c'è
veramente un sacco di fuochi d'artificio
vediamo dove cacchio arrivo di giorno
devo tenere sott'occhio le liti tra
tantissimo e questo sicuro e non sembra
davanti così assimila proprio la spinta
ok
vabbè io li uso praticamente tutti i
ragazzi che se noi li tramis mi sismica
ma è veramente stupenda questa cosa che
sto facendo ragazzo troppo rossetto ciao
big manila è stato bello nell'alta sono
sempre nella big manila ma solo nella
parte remota della big one di là perché
il server è lo stesso me ne vado solo
come superman sparisco non so quanto
duri effettivamente la dura vita alla
diva della sirena visioni là delle litra
secondo me i ragazzi mi si spacca prima
le lì tra cioè adesso anzi sto anche
molto attento perché io ho una paura
immonda che mi si spacchi levitra perché
se vi si spacca nell'italo lo devo
rifare
vedo che ci sono c'è un villaggio l'ex
co bellissimo non mi fermo raga perché
se mi fermo per qualsiasi cosa facciamo
notte a proposito di fare notte mi sa
che sta arrivando la notte ma almeno
sbatto le balle perchè tanto sta volando
non so quanto effettivamente duri la
litra mentre volo c'è una primati
portali e il network ci sono pazzesca
sta roba
ci sono un sacco in giro ci sono creati
un sacco di portali di uscita dal
network fantastico io me ne volo le
scuole o peccato il pieno un maiale
fantastico allora siamo parecchio
distanti già ma non voglio praticamente
andare fino a che le liti tra nomi su
nomi sismica e se riesco ad andare anche
oltre oceano è meglio infatti se
bloccandolo ci hanno in questo momento
perché l'oceano e ciò che separa
veramente la v balilla dal mondo esterno
i ghiacciai braga stiamo andando
totalmente fuori rotta totale cioè
proprio non sono anche dove sto andando
ho superato l'oceano con le lì tra ci
sono generate sono ancora nel mezzo
dell'oceano con l'edito ragazze due ore
che come mezzo all'oceano e pazzesca
salvare 44 cielo c'è non raga aiuto sono
veramente in un posto dove non tornerò
mai più indietro forse sarà bellissimo
creare una serie dove c'era il dovere
poi arriva doveri cerco di tornare a
casa tipo torna a casa lassie ma confavi
j fa finendo la durabilità delle lettere
tra l'altro e notte quindi se anche se a
terra lo devo stare attento proprio
bellissimo la barriera con la lean
corallina
c'è una guerra mi fermo basta basta
basta basta suonato lontanissimo sono
lontanissimo
non ho idea di che cosa ci sia qua
dunque una botta con le dita perfetto mi
fermo mi fermo qua mi fermo qua che un
posto bellissimo tra l'altro c'è la
barriera corallina spente splendido e
splendido però c'è un perfetto sono
cascato devo stare attento perché se mi
se voglio risparmio
porca vacca me ne vado sott'acqua guarda
tutto sono farmi pia dagli zombie mi
scavo sotto terra può essere perché se
muoio respondo nella mia casa e questo
potrebbe essere un problema allora lo
score di scavo sotto perché ciao mais o
allora devo stare attento scusatemi e mi
faccio il letto lag anche se
effettivamente c'era non c'e nessuno
essendo che mi faccio letto e dormo
allora madonna che aspettando la bei
ragazzi non so che dire veramente è
veramente pazzesco cioè into richter ica
mente io vorrei farmi una casa vicino
alla barriera corallina ed era
esattamente
non so per quale motivo era il mio
desiderio e sono arrivato vicinissimo
altro ho rispettato los von point rai
ormai è fatta non sono più non sono più
alibi per tornare indietro devo prendere
una direzione pazzesca non sono più
nella zona dei ragazzi totalmente fuori
allora signori dopo due ore di perché
voi non avete tutto col taglio la magia
dei tagli dopo due ore e no due renault
ma un'oretta e mezza tutta se uno arriva
qua vedete che non c'è niente no
totalmente c'è questa landa desolata
incredibile bellissima tra l'altro c'è
un campo lui mi guarda strano salve dopo
tutto sto casino se tu vai vicino al
pollice un buchino dove io ho fa ho
utilizzato produce anche prendere un po
da fuori perché non mi bastava
utilizzato un po di legno fatto questo
ma chicca chi è questo mais parlato
adesso non c'era però giuro che non
c'era prima porsche
maledizione la vita non c'è ragione non
c'era prima
vabbè ho creato sta roba qua che non è
male che non è male più che altro mi
preme il fatto che secondo me se siamo
dall'altra parte della mappa totalmente
perché siamo dall'altra parte della
mappa lasko io deve essere totalmente
segreto a parer mio è poi non so se
siete d'accordo però parer mio è così
basta che spesso non ci vuole nulla però
per adesso vi anzi facciamo subito o
stato sta roba per chiaramente ragazzi
era inguardabile che era simmetrica
adesso più o meno e ci siano almeno a
livello di simmetria poi per il resto
chissenefrega
e allora la città non l'ho fatta verano
ci sono fatta la faccio non è così che
si fa la cesta magari ok questo lo uso
solo come base e giusto per metterci la
roba dentro adesso quindi mi metto la
roba che effettivamente mi serve giusto
per non perderla perché se no se perdo
questo è finita e almeno abbiamo tutto
quanto al sicuro almeno le cose
importanti così posso farvi un giretto e
vedere un po che cosa c'è nei dintorni
almeno sappiamo nei prossimi episodi che
diavolo tiro fuori da qua allora la
questa roba qua il secchio e rotta serve
perché voglio fare un sistema qua sotto
un sistema di coltivazioni a campi
incredibili voglio farlo tutto qua le
torce va bene il sole tende o va bene
intanto non è che mi servono più di
tanto visto che so è teoricamente giorno
sono vado a dormire tanto sono davvero
nei server non è giorno devo fare la
botola ora che ci pensa dall'alto cioè
no avevano faccio ci vuole niente
ok mi piace mi è sempre piaciuto ora che
sa fare sta cosa vi giuro
la cosa più bella di minecraft da quando
ci gioco da quando è uscito
sostanzialmente io ci gioco dal 2009
2008 2009 2010
adesso non mi ricordo bene comunque da
quando c'è esiste minecraft la cosa più
bella che la parte più bella di
minecraft per me per me e lorenzo è
sempre stata quella di ci voleva una
scala in più mi sa prova niente è sempre
stata assolutamente quella di crearsi un
posto totalmente sconosciuto e di farci
casali in modo tale che non nessuno si
accorgesse di dove stai non so perché
ciò soprattutto questo feticismo
incredibile vivi se mi è piaciuta sta
roba ballo a prendere innanzitutto i
golden nugget che sono rimasti lava
allora mi prendo tutte le robe che ci
sono la sotto prima cosa in assoluto a
all right madonna che casino cercare
stato arrivare figo e non solamente come
farà tornare indietro ma più che altro
secondo un guardato video non sa come
arrivare a casa mia impossibile sta cosa
ok va bene non è che ci fosse tantissimo
mi sa che ce ne sono due e corretto
ce ne sarà un'altra che cazzo non ci
passo mai quando è così ok perfetto mi
dimentico se vedo schiacciare contro lo
adesso per nuotare ok
eccola lo sapevo lo sapevo non lo
sentivo madonna ok allora 3 ceste
neanche i fiocchi vetro così tante di
solito come ci siamo
usciamo un attimo vediamo la mappa del
tesoro dove lo fa provare se me lo fa
trovare
burri ed thrasher ma vediamo ok devo
entrare devo entrare assolutamente
interrotta se non casinò credo che
seguendo la riva riuscirò ad arrivarci
perché effettivamente io vedo che c'è il
mare li quindi secondo me tipo a destra
in fondo vediamo speriamo non sia troppo
distante ragazzi che qua e qua ferri si
fermi
ah beh allora era era abbastanza vicino
perché mi sono mosso da abbastanza
vicino sinceramente sono qua sopra e
sono entrati in sto canale andata bene è
andata bene e quindi era abbastanza
vicina attenzione raga non ho mai capito
esattamente dove dovrebbe trovarsi sì
però se mi faceva una pala magari era
meglio visto che non ce l'ho
maledizione sono andati in giro senza
palla proprio in mezzo all'acqua melo da
non fare checa fuoco come niente vabbè
dai proviamoci
poi ci metto a scavare due ore eccolo
subito cuore dello share sa che non so
che cos'è mi sa che l'avevo trovato già
una volta ma non ho idea di cosa sia
attenzione faccio un altro giro
non male quale nell'oceano adesso
controllo che serve effettivamente credo
che si venda un sacco di esordi nero fa
niente il cuore l'oceano e colori di
tale titanic era sostanzialmente ok
write
ferri nice non è stato anche difficile
va bene io volevo andare a fare un
giretto ma già che abbiamo trovato un
tesoro nice
mi guardo la tv in giro ragazzo non mi
dispiace giusto per capire che bello
però cioè è tutto completamente
inesplorato suo posto rara fighissimo
va bene allora facciamo così io mi sa
che concluso quale episodio perché siamo
veramente nel mezzo del della terra di
nessuno totale ma continueremo nel
prossimo e naufraghi stasera niente
altro che vi in vanilla ma naufraghi
spero che il viso che sia piaciuto
ragazzi tornerò indietro un giorno con
le dita ma nel frattempo farò
colonizzano questo posso una maniera più
totale perché troppo bello la barriera
corallina con con la batte nessuno e
ragazze possa essere sincero non la
batte nessuno come al solito ragazzi
schede al canale lasciato momento è un
mi piace
e noi come e reus prima che questi mi
facciano fuori torniamo a casa
se dio vuole non mi sono tanto tanto vi
giuro
da qua e cerca una strada di casa
intanto chiudo il video beh ragazzi
[Musica]